Monica is with us in California hey
Monica welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi
better than I deserve how are you um so
here's my question mostly to do its
hottest stay hopeful and motivated
during the debt free journey going
through some hardships as well I've been
living out of my car about eight months
and I'm just barely being able to get by
and don't know how to I can see the
light I think I do a total watches like
I was when I first started the journey
what city in California are you tonight
outskirts of le okay and how did you end
up in the car what happened to your
place well I did something stupid and I
moved in with my Alex boyfriend and then
he ended up cheating on me so and when I
tried going back to my parents but my
dad didn't want to help me and then my
mom didn't have much of a say because
she's a stay-at-home mom and my dad does
dictate the world this is my heart why
didn't why didn't he want to help I
guess he is it's mostly bitter that I
walked out but I tried apologizing many
times already
he just won't hear he wanted you to live
with him forever
yeah that's what it felt like he didn't
want you to go to school here are you
doing the argue you have any kind of
work that you're doing I was doing
massage therapy I got diagnosed with
carpal tunnel and my doctor said that it
would be better if I stopped because
then they would just get worse and that
wouldn't be able to use my hands as
often okay so you're not you're not
employed right now I am I'm working for
Leslie sling post place and I work as a
customer representative for Domino's
okay so how much are you making I
already applied for higher positions
both my jobs make sure you have $1,500 a
month coming in yes and why have you not
been able to get a place with $1,500 a
month coming in you don't pay credit
card bills when you're living in your
car so we can just stop that right now
what else at one of the bills are you
paying off my car more than the monthly
payment I'm trying yes okay how much is
your car payment and I have two thousand
dollars left on it what's the car worth
I checked on Kelly's book it's worth it
why honey say it again it's worth $1,000
and you've had a $380 car payment on it
yeah I bought it off my friend but I
didn't realize at the time was that dumb
decision that was okay so what's going
on is is that you are prioritizing an
income that you have
and that you're prioritizing the income
wrong and that's why you're in this
situation so that's great news all we
have to do is reprioritize so let me
give you the priorities for your money
okay the first thing you do is eat the
second thing you do is you pay utilities
on the new place that you rent lights
and water the third thing you pay is
rent and you don't pay credit cards or
anything else until you do those things
basic necessities of life shelter and
utilities and food you have
transportation and apparently that's
getting ready to be paid off fairly soon
but you don't pay extra on your car
instead of renting a place to live
because you're the quality of your life
is taking your hope away and taking your
dignity away and all of that is simply
because of the choices you made with the
money of coming in so let's just choose
differently with the money that's coming
in let's get you a place so here's what
I'm going to do and we'll put you on
hold and I want to do two things number
one I want to connect you to a good
church in that area that we work with
that has Financial Peace University and
they'll help you and maybe give you a
leg up and help you get into that get
the deposit up or something and get
started in the first place and the
second thing we're going to put you in
one of our financial coaches who can
help you sit down and look at this stuff
but the the problem with all of us
including when I lost millions including
when you moved out with your boyfriend
including when you moved in with your
boyfriend including when you decide to
pay extra on your car and pay credit
card payments instead of getting a place
to live there by choosing to pay extra
on your credit cards and extra on your
car in and choosing to live in your car
all of these are choices they're all
decisions and the good news is is that
you can make different choices and after
I went broke I learned I make different
choices so I don't go broke again and
you make different choices in how you
interact with your dad and you make
different choices and the type of man
you choose to be around and not end up
being susceptible
to a situation like this again and so
that's the great news is that you can
take all of these things that have
happened and they become lessons for
your future and you can look back and go
yeah I remember back you can tell your
grandkids I remember back there and you
know all 19 I was living in my car
and by the way Anthony O'Neill lived in
his car for a while and he's a ramsey
personality now making hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year and has had
a number one best-selling book this year
so how do you get hope you get traction
how do you get traction you make
different choices than the choices that
have caused you to lose traction and you
start very specifically step by step by
step setting micro goals and hitting
those goals and so no extra payments on
anything right now and no luxuries of
any kind you're homeless in your car the
first thing you do is get out of the car
and the good news is you've got enough
money coming and to pull this off
you're not calling me up with absolutely
no income I mean you're making 1,500 to
2,000 dollars a month and you could
probably even make more so this is great
news hang on Kelly I'll pick up and
we'll walk with you kiddo
sometimes you just need someone to push
the foot trees back so you can see the
forest and we're really good at that and
we'll walk with you and love you well so
we'll hook you up with one of our
coaches and with a church in your area
to get you to the next stage on this